the record number of Americans expected
to hit the road this holiday weekend
many come in right here to Las Vegas and
while you'll find plenty to do on and
off to strip Airbnb is halting any plans
for party houses on the fourth and
Beyond Madison Kimbrough on this story
live in our Newsroom with more in the
permanent band Madison it is now in
place yeah this announcement coming just
a week after short-term rentals were
given the green light here in
unincorporated Clark County and with
this permanent ban now in place many
will have to find a new place to party
elsewhere across the valley
I don't mind if they're in my
neighborhood at all really as long as
they're not super loud having parties
Airbnb putting a permanent ban on all
parties and events at their listings
globally this comes after a temporary
ban was put in place back in August of
2020 due to the pandemic and social
distancing requirements Airbnb stating
that just in Nevada alone they have seen
a 77 percent year-over-year drop in
party reports since implementing the
policy so how do people across the
valley and fellow hosts feel about this
I mean I think it's good someone's gotta
put a rule down otherwise people aren't
going to respect you know just an owner
saying oh you can't have parties I mean
it goes in sync with what most Property
Owners want to see at their house they
don't want their houses to be rented or
out of control events or parties it's
and people work and it's actually it can
be a real disturbance to people who have
families and we have casinos we have day
clubs we have night clubs we have
24-hour clubs and people can go to of
those and as for people who don't want
to follow the guidelines Airbnb
releasing this statement that reads the
policy will continue to include serious
consequences for guests to attempt to
violate these rules varying from account
suspension to full removal from the
platform
and Clark County plans to step up
enforcement on airbnbs as well they will
be having a 24-hour phone number for
people to report issues to the county
and Code Enforcement Officers to
investigate complaints now regulations
go into place that's going to be next
spring in The Newsroom Madison Kimbrough
live local now